you we need to wait now for the police
report
well i don't think we do when we know
now that the prime minister is a liar
everything that you've just played was a
lie a lie a lie and the problem is
that you only govern in this country by
consent and that consent relies on a
golden thread
which is the moral authority of the
prime minister
we've always had a rule in the house
commons that you can't say in the house
of commons that a member of parliament
is dishonorable or that they've lied and
but that that rule was always there
because in previous generations wherever
whenever a minister was even accused of
lying
they resigned because that was the
honorable thing to do
and my anxiety is that
the the nation faces major problems you
know the cost of living crisis the fuel
crisis energy and all the rest of it the
prime minister can't lead on the back of
that he said something very interesting
i thought yesterday it was a strange
turn of phrase he said
we must look ourselves in the mirror
but the truth is he's got to look
himself in the mirror
and this is precisely who he is
he's been sacked twice before for lying
he's a proven liar and he came to the
house of commons twice in november and
december last year and said
categorically that they were all the
rules were followed no guidelines were
broken
and now we know because sue gray in her
report which incidentally is just the
tip of the iceberg it's just 12 pages at
the 500 pages
she has said
very simply
that there are events that should never
have happened and that there was a
failure of leadership in in downey
street that buck stops with the prime
minister and all i'd say to conservative
mps is you knew this was coming
you know it will come again because a
leopard just doesn't change his spots
this is the government that he will
always be
one that breaks the rules
tells lies and is unable to lead and
they were aware of that and they still
elected him as prime minister so why
will they change that night
well conservatives i think are beginning
to realize that they're complicit in all
these lies because every time they have
to defend it and they don't necessarily
come on your program to defend it i'm
guessing it's quite difficult to get
people to come on from the conservative
party at the moment but lots of them are
terribly anguished about it you know
many only got elected in 2019 and
they're just
well it's like aaron bell yesterday i
thought was the most moving of the lot
when he said look
i went to my grandmother's funeral i i
drove all the way there and i i didn't
hug anybody we were hardly allowed to
have anybody there i didn't hug my
siblings my parents i didn't go back to
the house i got back in the car went
home
was i a full prime minister
and that's the problem you know you can
only govern
with moral authority
that's about leadership it's one of the
fundamental principles of how we run our
country and um i was in um as i think
you know i was i was in ukraine uh two
weeks ago
part of the foreign affairs trip
massively important set of issues i've
been arguing about i i think i've
probably been
putin's great strongest critic in the
house of commons now for the best part
of 15 years i chair the all-party russia
group i care passionately about making
sure that there's not an invasion of
ukraine but the prime minister can't
lead in that if if putin picks the phone
up to him eventually he'll just laugh at
him
and that's what i i
as you know i was also very briefly for
about two and a half minutes a foreign
office minister i know
um what it looks like in another capital
city when reports come back from your
ambassadors of problems um in that
country we are a laughingstock as long
as boris johnson remains in office a
complete and utter
laughter
what's most important at the moment mr
bryant though is him having the support
at home in order to stay in his job and
uh the um
the dcms um
secretary of state and nadine doris was
very relaxed about coming on the
airwaves yesterday to support him we had
the deputy prime minister on the show
this morning i've had ministers on the
show over the last couple of weeks there
are other back benches who will come on
and support him hugh merriman people
like that so you know he does have the
support and as a result he's going
nowhere i don't think he has the support
of the british people and as andrew
mitchell well it was interesting two
former chief wits uh mark harper and
andrew mitchell and of course former toy
leader theresa may um yesterday
basically pointing out that he hasn't
got the moral authority he needs now to
leave the country
or the conservative party but but more
importantly andrew mitchell's saying
today that this is as corrosive as
battery acid um on the reputation of the
conservative party now look for partisan
reasons i suppose i should want boris
johnson to stay there all the way
and keep him there because every time
all of these people come on the
television they're writing you know
literature for the labor party to put
out in elections my suspicion is that
quite a lot of conservatives have
decided that they want to get rid of him
but they're going to wait until after
the local elections in may
but i i i just despair
i think this is doing more damage to
parliament's reputation and it's not
just that the boris answers but to
parliament's reputation and more
importantly to the nation's reputation
than anything we've seen in the last 20
years
it's just lie after lie half truth after
half truth and the narcissism
of the prime minister is at the heart of
the problem as i said earlier and a
leopard doesn't change his thoughts
there will be more of these issues
the jennifer r curry that issue was
still got to come back there's the whole
issue about what happened in afghanistan
we haven't finished learning all the
truths about that and we've only had 12
pages out of 500 um from sue gray when
all of that is out in the open
i hear your frustration i hear your
frustration but at the end of the day
the opposition of whatever flavor can do
nothing about it unless tory back
benches and tory front benchers doing
unless the grand deals go in with the
revolver and the whiskey there's nothing
to be done
okay i know that's the frustration of
being in opposition that's why i always
prefer a labor party that can win
elections
and and and that's why
i think everybody in the labour party
that i know is just so determined that
we will win the trust of the british
people before the next election because
we cannot have this shower of
shenanigans running the country any
longer